We do have to do something about this. And I will continue like
I think I might ramp up my hostility. Go ahead.
Go ahead. Ramp up your hostility,
sucker. This is the dark woke thing? Oh no. SUCK MY
SMOKE THEM IF YOU GOT THEM, BABY.
>> Oh yes. I'm going to get the sweatiest losers to be
even more sweaty. Bring it
>> Now the main the main contention we're looking at today,
okay, is Asmongold
>> versus
Hasan [__] okay. So Hasan started his stream today.
He starts off talking about the Emmy thing, just referencing
it, okay. Hasan [__] comments on the Emiru ice
I've seen like Emiru apology stuff. I was going to talk about
it because like Asmongold apparently like Emiru got yelled at.
Emiru got yelled at cuz woke is back. Oh. And and apparently
that like turned into a whole thing. Asmongold responded. I'm
not going to go to the response. I'm going to go to Hasan
watching Asmongold's response, okay. We've got the
Hasan [__] vod here. He's going to talk about it
because like Asmongold apparently like Emiru got yelled at cuz
woke is back. We do have to do something about this. And I will
continue like I think I might ramp up my hostility. Go ahead.
Go ahead. Ramp up your hostility,
OH, WHAT? WAIT, I thought that was like homophobic to say what
is there something bad about
bro, what happened? This is dark woke I
This is the dark woke thing? Oh no. SUCK
SMOKE THEM IF YOU GOT THEM, BABY. WOO!
OH, YES.
Go ahead.
I'll be honest, I don't I'm not a huge fan of the way he's saying
it, but whatever. Go ahead, baby. Keep going. Oh, yeah. I'm a
fan of the sentiment. The way he's saying it, I'm like, "Ah."
But, you know, I'm a fan of the sentiment. I'm a fan of the sentiment.
>> I'm going to get the sweatiest
losers to be even more sweaty.
Bring it on. I've been dealing with this [__] For
the record, they're pretending that it hasn't because you, her
head mod, said Hasanat. Yeah, her head mod, who apparently is
Asmongold's moderator as well from what I understand, was still
calling me out.
Even in that like inception of
Emiru responding to her head mod that created this entire ordeal
for her. Okay? The head mod was also still making a Hasan joke,
it seems.
for the people online that are pushing these woke narratives.
I think we might need to ramp it up and be even more militant
and aggressive at these people.
Bring it on.
Suck my dick.
I think Hasan regrets not getting involved. I think Hasan's been
I sometimes I like saying things on stream and I'm like, "Dude,
they are listening." Cuz I swear to god, with both Mizkif and
Hasan, I told them they weren't invested enough that like, "Hey,
guess what? You can opt out of this. You can go, 'Well, I'm not
terminally online. I don't want to participate in this kind of
thing.'" It's like, "Okay, then you're just going to lose." You're
like a country who's who's had war declared against them, and
you're sitting there and you're like, "We are pacifists. We don't
fight." It's like, "Yeah, you're already." What the [__]
are you doing? Don't sit around and do nothing. You're
Where's the
>> Let me do a reference, okay? You Lord of the Rings Two
Towers.
We will not throw I will not risk open war. Well, guess what?
Open war is upon you, okay? Whether you would risk it or not.
There you go. There's a reference for you guys, okay? That it's
there. It's literally there. These people are coming after you.
They will come after you no matter what you do. You can opt to
try to like sit out, but you're just opting to let your throat
get cut. That's all you're doing. So, you better actually lean
in and do something. Can't lean out.
Can't lean out. >> Done peach. Got to lean in.
Uh Dickers Thank you very much for the gifted sub. I suspect
that is Max, but I don't know for sure. Thank you very much Dickers.
I appreciate the gifted sub. Thank you. >> you have to
be a lot You all are both getting one guy. I don't think anyone
cares about this one. You're wrong because the numbers actually
disprove what you're saying. Even on Twitter, which is supposed
to be a neo-Nazi sh He's literally talking about organizing harassment
brigades. >> Yeah, you got normies making fun of Emma Ru
because of this. Yeah, you're Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. So,
he's talking about organizing harassment brigades kind of kind
of. But, if they're just going to ask like the kind of questions
that are getting asked of Emmy, like, what do you think about
Ice? Hey, why don't you make a statement? I would say
realistically, he's looking to hit back at anybody who is, you
know, repeating some of the stuff about Emmy that she's like
a fascist or a racist or something. That's probably I don't think
You can't have a 42 million view tweet blow up and then go, "Oh,
if you if you want to like organize something against this, you
you're just organizing harassment
Now, Asmongold the way Asmongold states it sounds a little bit
more like a harassment campaign. It's not like Hasan was directing
people to go after Emma Ru, right?
Asmon is starting to steal takes and words from both you and
Mike now. I know. I know. Mike from PA has been going hard on
this and you said 10 words and they come at you. Yeah, because,
once again,
I am seen as like the beacon of woke for these people. I've talked
oftentimes about Yeah, look, this person said this has no significance
whatsoever. This has 41 million views, dude. 41 million views.
>> No, there it is, finally. >> Oh, Asmongold goes,
"Hey, we got to get more aggressive. What are you going to do
about it?" Oh, we have a Twitter harassment community.
So, just what you've been doing already. What you've been doing
already. Keep up. Keep at it. I'll keep tanking that [__]
Let me tell you something.
I was tanking that [__] when no one else would take
a [__] stand. You think now I'm scared? Are you [__]
kidding me? Yeah, they're getting flamed into oblivion right
now. Emiru's getting flamed into oblivion. Emiru's face when
she asked to comment on ice random people and racially profile
America's, but she just a babe who cosplays and is friends with
a bunch of grifters. Oh,
>> Asmongold brought about a Hasan STARK SEGMENT. OH, NO.
I DON'T have any We're starking Emiru now? Oh, no. >> issues
Oh, no. with Emiru. Okay, I don't have Oh, oh, he has no issues.
Oh, never mind. He has no issues. Cancel. Cancel the starking
session. No issues with Emiru, although he was just listening.
He was just looking at the memes. >> issues with Emiru
whatsoever.
What the [__] is this? [laughter] Somebody stuck
this in. Somebody was like, "Hasan, important context." And he
clicked it and just opened it without paying attention. Cat detector,
the truth comes out.
Okay. But, let's That really [__] with his flow,
okay? Ban that chatter. Ban that chatter. He [__]
with the flow of the stream. Ban that chatter immediately. That
chatter [__] everything up, okay?
Okay. But, let's be real. It is odd that she is like directly
aligned with a bunch of these [__] right? It's weird
because it was her head mod that her asked asked her about Ice
while attacking Hasan. Did she set this up with her head mod
to open an attack on the left? They're coming after her when
no one even asked. It's not my fault all your close friends are
Nazis. I don't think this is like a grand conspiracy, Michael
from Pennsylvania. I think
Ali Kitty, her head mod, was just basically making a joke. So,
what are your thoughts on Ice_Poseidon?
is so dumb. Like, what is a streamer saying Ice validated? Makes
no sense. If a streamer saying Ice
is not that consequential,
then why do you guys mald so much?
Yeah, I think Ice_Poseidon is code for Sinna, right? They They
have to turn everything back to They have to basically turn everything
back to like something that like I taught people to hate Ice
as though as though that's the reason Hassan controls everybody's
opinions cuz everybody's scared of Hassan's audience, and so
they all agree with Hassan.
Actually, it's just everybody Everybody agrees with Hassan. Hassan
controls all of the wokes, and the wokes go around and threaten
people with machetes.
That's the way it works. >> Why Sinna has that opinion
on Ice? They're so stupid.
Yes, they were They were making a joke about Sinna.
The story starts with Sinna and all these other content creators
that are now coming out, and Sinna has been there since day one.
Let's be real.
Talking about how, you know, Ice is ridiculous with all this
Ice Ice all this stuff.
He's passively influential, no? Uh he is not a cultural I I fully
believe that Hassan surfs a cultural wave. He does not create
the cultural
And he's like the attractive face of a wave that he doesn't control.
I not I don't want to you know, I don't want to [__]
talk him, but he is not he is not the controlling factor there.
I don't think anybody's ever thought Hassan's like the the, you
know,
the complex planning type who's like making this thing work.
Yeah, I wouldn't say that. >> You're 4 days late to this
drama discourse, so everyone on our side is conspiracy and schizoid
out. They're speculating
about our relationship now. What Okay, that is just funny, okay?
And also, incredibly Listen,
you can say it's schizo, but unfortunately, those Emmy schizos
are just right every single time. I hate to say it. Okay, you
can say it's schizo. I'll agree it's schizo. Are you betting
against them? Are you betting against them? Is anyone betting
against those people? I'm telling you I will not I will not bet
against them.
So, the long arc of history bends towards Emiru obsessed schizophrenics,
This is just facts. I don't know what to tell you. Okay, it's
a huge self-report they cannot possibly form opinions without
getting notes from someone else, so they assume SinA or whoever
is getting their notes removed. Yeah.
Uh why do you think Denims called out Emiru specifically? Because
Emiru will take opinions from the exact political streamers who
she says she doesn't like even really she's not really associated
with or whatever, and she'll say them when it comes to the Ethan
Klein thing. Right? Those lawsuits, which are inherently political,
which were driven from a political lens, right? The Israel-Palestine
situation. So, Emmy will comment then, but then when she doesn't
want to have to go and disavow those people, she will say I don't
talk about that stuff at all.
You know what I'm saying? That's probably why
Denims is a little choked. He's like, "Hey, when you're uninformed
and you're just going to comment on my lawsuits, you're totally
fine to do it. Totally fine to dog pile me. How about you get
dog piled back, bitch?"
Which, you know, we love spiteful queens here when it provides
us content, okay? Also, welcome to the Twitch chat. >> who
sent Trump to democracy. Go protest
>> Well, people are actually protesting. If you're if you
need a streamer who doesn't even know anything about politics
to tell you about politics, you probably just need to like get
off the internet. Like just stop. Like like hello? Like
this this take in and of itself
This take in and of itself is also like
interesting because like there are a lot of people because he
has a shared audience with Asmongold.
raids her all the time. They have a podcast together. Man, lean
back. Lean back, Hasan. What the [__] was that? >> A
lot of her shared audience gets their notes from a political
Stinky gassy >> content creator. What is going on?
Like it or not, unfortunately, this is the grand design. And
for me Get this Get this guy some black tape stat, okay? For
me at least I I try to provide like some information for people,
you know what I mean? I try to do like news coverage. I was with
the DSA slate yesterday.
I collaborate with you know, people who I align with ideological
I don't know why that's I don't know why I don't know why I don't
know what that has to do with this, okay? from you know, Zarah
Momandani all the way to
Asmongold doesn't do any of that [__] He's just chirping.
Like a reactionary mouthpiece, like a bot that's just like feeding
into a machine the most right-wing position that is palatable
at the time. Okay.
And his audience loves that [__] >> Oh, I see.
So like you have a bunch of people who get their opinions from
somebody like that already, somebody who openly says they don't
even watch [__] They're just they they go off of
their intuitions based on things they know about psychology,
right? They go off their intuitions. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure.
Sure. Sure. Sure. I don't Like what? Like >> How am I going
to I don't know. Get help. Like even like
I don't know.
Like this I'll be honest, this to me reveals that like she knows
where her bread is buttered.
Like she knows that like a big chunk of her audience is a bunch
of racist chuds. >> Okay. Yes. Yes. >> the reason
why she's trying to like not come out with a with a statement
and is instead tackling the question itself by being like, "Why
are you asking me? I'm a I'm just a content creator." I don't
know what that is. I don't know what that is. I genuinely have
no idea what that I get
I don't think it's just mental illness. I do get the impression
that he watches a lot, okay? I I get that impression. I get that
feeling.
One second. >> What is your opinion on Ice? He doesn't
know what that is. I don't know what you're talking about.
What is Hasan at?
I don't know what
Oh, no, I know what Ice is. I I thought
I do. Like there's a certain extent where I'm like, "Okay, sure.
I get people wanting
big content creators to like say their opinions on like important
topics. I get that, right?"
The catalyst for all this was actually Emiru complaining about
people talking about how she'd never talk about anything political,
not even the Epstein files or in other streamers' chats, which
then prompted the Hasan comp uh comparison by her head mod, which
they then 12 minutes later brought
Some schizo was spamming my DMs saying Nick is in the files,
and I was like, "Good for you, dude." Our words be Male feminist
xqcL6969420xd
What a What a tag. >> you're Hasan. Yeah, what a lot of
people don't understand is like I am seen as like for a lot of
these people, they have no understanding of politics, they have
no understanding of like uh you know, why people are voting for
whoever. They just think about it in terms of personality. Many
of you have a hard time comprehending this because you're a little
bit better versed in the field of politics because I try to educate
you on things that are, you know, far beyond myself and my own
personal fancy, okay? If you think in terms of drama only when
you talk about politics, everything goes back to people like
myself.
Because I happen to be the largest left-wing content creator
in North True. True. I can I can see this. I often try
That was um the person who told me to do this all the time, who
I take this advice from, is actually Destiny's
August told me this. He's like, "Basically, if you're making
YouTube thumbnails, if you're trying to like make a story interesting,
figure out how to tie it to a big name."
Literally just figure out your angle to tie to a big name, and
that's not to go after Hasan. That wasn't it. He was just trying
to give me advice for my own YouTube channel. He's like, "If
you tie big names in, people will click. It'll drive It'll drive
traffic.
August talks to you still? No, it'd probably be a little weird
for me to hang out with somebody who Well, I don't even know
if he gets paid anymore. But
someone who was like hanging out with a guy who like is a gigadoxer.
The only reason why it's it's it's you know, having a lot of
impact in this space
is because
streamers are endlessly accessible, okay? That's why. And people
develop parasocial relationships that can go either in either
direction, either tremendous amounts of love or tremendous amounts
of hatred, and it can flip
And that's the reason why. For some reason, it's accepted to
see right-wing takes as casual, but you can't say anything left
is because then you're political. Exactly.
Exactly. So, the reason why I think the reason why Emiru doesn't
want to say anything here is because she doesn't want to offend
the sensibilities of uh her her audience. They used to call Bruce
Hasan anytime he disagreed with Kai or Rage about saying the
R word or even over the fact that he would ban transphobic chatters.
Your name has always been used as a negative comparison with
other streamers act in moral ways. I know.
Because they see me as as the representation of everything that
is like virtue signaling. >> We've gone through a lot of
it. I don't need to Everything that is objectively
like caring about like having an empathetic worldview, caring
about marginalized communities, but because they see
everything that is a representation of that as like a demonstration
of Has There's like this is not as bad as I feel like he's making
it right now. I do think there's like a a thing where on Twitch
or in the Twitch adjacent spaces, people see the performative
lefty virtue signal stuff as Hassan related. Sure. I I would
grant them that, right?
But I think I don't think he's quite synonymous with like anything
>> outcome of that that idiotic way of seeing the world.
>> is uh a close associate of Asmongold and was a close
associate It's also doubly
uh it's it's doubly controversial because Emiru is uh a close
associate of Asmongold and was a close associate until recently
and I don't even know if she actually spoke out about it with
uh with Lacari and also Teccy.
People like Asmongold can consistently repeat this notion that
like they will punish anyone that speaks out, but it's going
to get Woke is returning except we can call Asmongold the F-slur
now, okay? I I see we I was never in the woke crowd, but yeah,
that's that's a That was my stakes. That was my table stakes
for joining the woke movement, okay? Got to be able to call this
guy an F-slur. If I can't do that, then I'm out. I'm
Thank you. >> where he is an island. Just as as someone
who was an anti-Zionist for, you know, 10 to 12 years prior to
uh October 7th, very publicly, I always felt isolated from my
peers even in the progressive community when I uh maintained
this position. Nowadays, I don't feel so isolated, okay? Why
don't I feel so isolated? Because nowadays, people who are pro-Israel
are actually stigmatized and isolated. This kind of social pressure
plays a big role because a lot of people don't have the political
education, they don't go on this journey on their own, and they
just go along with whatever the [__] prominent cultural
undertones look like. People like Teccy, Teccy, people like Asmongold
were the domineering force on the internet. If you were an extremely
online [__] all you saw was drama. Hassan Don did
it again. He's going to go to prison this time. He's going to
get shot in this time. Ethan Klein was doing it. Right? Asmongold
was doing it. Rep Tone was doing it. All of the other all of
the other like cultural commentators in the drama sphere were
doing it. And unfortunately, whether we want to admit it or not,
a lot of these guys despite being, you know,
pro-Israel, it didn't matter because that was they had a a collectively
they had a pretty strong grip on
creating social pressure and making it seem like most people's
position reflected their psychotic worldview.
And that's why I kept saying over and over again, if people don't
push back against this stuff, this is all they hear. This is
all the people in the margins hear. They're going to start thinking,
"Oh, it's not fashionable to be to to have Hasan's worldview."
I hate that that is unfortunately the only way that people understand
politics, but
it is all personality-based. And on the personality-based political
front, I ate a lot of [__] for the last 2 years.
And therefore, Hasan, Hasan, I know that you I know that you
Hasan, I know that you suffered, but can we get to Can we get
back to the Hasan, I know you suffered, Hasan. I know. Nobody
knows better than me how much you've suffered. Can we get back
to the Can we just, you know, with the drama the drama the Emiru
the Wig Wilder all this stuff. Can we Do you think it's harmful
for people to be able to farm off literal fascist creators and
then claim a political status? Yes, I I don't disagree with that.
I I I think so. I think it's ridiculous. I I could never understand
it because I'm pretty sure Uh-oh, he's trying to he's trying
to grant charity to Emiru, okay?
I know this feeling. He's trying to He's trying to grant charity
to Emiru, okay? Cuz he doesn't want to go after Emiru. Not a
good look, okay? As much as people everybody understands that
Emiru is like childlike, okay? Everybody understands that until
it comes to like her and then they're like, "No, this [__]
is an adult. She made her decisions."
You know? It's just not a good look for a lot of other people.
Yeah, yeah, she doesn't He doesn't want to push her away. And
then Mike's like, wait, do you think it's okay to like have these
fascist people feed you raids all the time and profit from that?
And then
to say nothing?
It's like, no. I have like trans relatives and Asmongold is endlessly
Uh Asmongold, this is the one thing that I don't get. I'm pretty
sure Asmongold is not endlessly transphobic, which in and of
itself is a tell at those Emmy skitsos being powerful, okay?
I think Asmongold's gone on rants explicitly against this community
trying to take the side of trans people.
Which again is a major tell, okay? To me at least.
Asmongold What's this one non like extreme right opinion that
Asmongold
Oh, it lines up with like the one thing you need to have, the
one opinion you need to have to not upset Emiru. Weird. That's
crazy. >> made the space uninhabitable for trans people.
Asmongold has gone Said trans parents are abusive. Did he say
trans parents are abusive or parents who are looking to trans
their kids before they've reached like age 10 are abusive?
gone after small trans content creators and has gloated about
going after and harassing small trans content creators and bullying
them into submission, bullying them into silence.
Emiru is a trans sibling. I could not understand how Emiru did
not, you know, at least have a private conversation with someone
like Asmongold on this issue either. It blows my mind. Anyway,
here is a Woke Wilder's take who once again has has been another
Woke Wilder, let's go.
There's some There's some Asmongold
bully. I'm looking for a tweet. I'm looking for a tweet right
now. >> brave woke warrior uh who is in the Austin sphere
of influence and and has never shied away from letting his takes
be known on this and is also routinely been yelled at. He's routinely
been called Hasan, by the way. Ironically enough, they love bringing
that [__] up. They love anyone and everyone that
says anything remotely empathetic, they're "Hasan brainwashed
you. Does he have blackmail on you?" No, man. This person is
a well-read individual, okay? He's a well-read individual who
has an empathetic worldview that doesn't You are only demonstrating
how stupid you and your friends are if your only association
with politics is whichever content creator you've been taught
to
Spoke out in favor of Ethan Klein. Wait,
Oh, you mean Asmongold spoke out in favor of Ethan Klein but
quiet on the Korean tectone. Emiru spoke out in favor of Ethan
Klein? Oh, no.
Oh Oh, no.
Emiru spoke out in favor of Ethan Klein?
Emiru defended Ethan Klein's lawsuits?
Let's listen to Hasan reacts to the lawsuit commentary.
react like they react to people they hate and they're like watch
me so that they don't get any views.
Like yeah, you you can't do that.
That's not good. Emiru here is talking about the Yeah, you can't
do that. That's not good. That's not good. >> Ethan Klein
lawsuits that were Okay. uh some of the biggest
uh some of it it it's the even the Ethan Klein lawsuit is like
one of the dumbest lawsuits of all time.
It was it's total harassment over commentary disguised as a legal
suit disguised as a lawsuit that's totally valid by abusing
the the existing
uh the existing protections over copyright. Okay? I I would put
Emiru in the like the law >> category of someone who Which
by the way, I think it's totally wrong to do this. It's like
totally legal obviously. >> I don't think you could argue
it's an abuse that it was like it was put in for people who had
a lot of power to maintain their money and it's like it's kind
of
It's It's explicitly meant to take people who don't really cause
damage, who in aggregate can cause harm and deal with them. And
she brought up the fact that, you know, Ethan's lawsuit is valid
because it brings up Uh, lawsuit is valid uh, because it's uh,
you know, they said, "Oh, I want you to watch me as a market
substitute or whatever the Yo, Snake, thanks for 8 months and,
uh, Henry, thank you for the 500 bits. Just What is this?
RIP KaceyTron? Why? She threw us under the bus to get the suit
thrown out? I don't give a [__] What are you talking
You never, ever in a million years should hold that over KaceyTron's
head. Are you [__] stupid? Are you insane? Oh, no.
Are you out of your [__] mind? If This kind of This
kind of nukes the idea that Hasan hates KaceyTron because KaceyTron
threw him under the bus. Anything it completely demonstrates,
it completely demonstrates how how insane Ethan Klein was, who
made KaceyTron apologize to Asmongold
in that same [__] lawsuit in order to settle the
lawsuit. Yeah, this is sort of why when I when I hear her say
she's like apolitical or when I hear people imply she's apolitical,
it's like I get the impression she does talk to Tectone and Asmongold
outside of, you know, streaming. And that
in my opinion, like if she has this take, she's probably got
some adjacent takes as well. And I don't think it's like that
weird to ask about some of the adjacent ones that you think are
I I don't think she has to answer, but I don't think it's weird
to ask. Dude,
in order to settle that lawsuit, she had to apologize to Asmongold
on top of saying like, "Oh, Hasan sucks. He never helped me."
Anything like that. As I've made my position clear. Whether I
helped KaceyTron or not, you will never know, okay? You will
never [__] know. Okay, I'm looking for I wanted to
cover this tweet before I get too far away from it. Just the
Asmongold enjoys bullying smaller streamers thing. Asmongold
enjoys it when small streamers are harassed for not supporting
ICE, but condemns it when his when it's his friend Emiru. Hypocrisy.
Hypocrisy. I'm glad that more creators are getting hate on social
media for not supporting ICE. Oh, we watch that. We watch that.
But at the end of the day, I'm glad that more people are starting
to speak up against it. And I'm glad that I'm going to be honest,
I'm glad that more creators are getting hate on social media
for not supporting ICE and for making virtue statements and and
statements and statements against Ice. I think that content creators
need to deserve I think they deserve and I think they need a
lot more hate and they need a lot more pushback for being able
to virtue signal about how bad Ice is. I do. I'm really glad
to see more people speaking up against it and uh you know, taking
a stand for uh these weirdos, right? Especially streamers. I
want to see it happen a lot more. Well, people get mad
Wow. Wow.
Wow. So, I think Asmongold, you know, you have to listen to Asmongold
and I hate to say
the thing that kind of applies to Hasan, but Asmongold's pretty
explicit in the way he says it. He's like, "I will always say
the thing that's most effective for my side."
Right? And
like I'm not going to be consistent.
And he's talked about how like he wants his ideas to win. So,
he's going to tell you that like it's evil for leftists to do
this and totally support right-wingers doing it. 100%, right?
And he's laid out the strategy for you. He's told you why he
does it. It's pretty clear that this would be the
Streamer Teekon challenges Hasan's father to fight his father.
By the way, do not get knocked out around my dad. Who knows what
he's going to do. Teekon's father was
>> Dude, Teekon's the rage. That's I'll be honest, if he
wasn't legitimately like a super harmful person, that would be
very funny to me. That's like a crazy
That is funny to me regardless. It's actually funny to me in
any case, but it's a little too real, unfortunately. Like him
and his dad are both a little too His his bloodline, unfortunately,
you know, Hasan pondered the orb. It's usually Vosh pondering
the orb. Hasan kind of pondered the orb on this one. You see,
you know it was his dad, you know it was him, but then you find
out his sister also did it to him. Jesus, man. was convicted
of 14 charges including harassing three women and assaulting
five women. I only read your ex's doc on you. That was enough
for me to think you're a monster. Don't make me call my dad.
You want him to rape me, too? This dude was trying to deploy
his dad like a nuke. Dude.
>> You know how like people say, "My dad can beat up your
dad?" >> I prefer I prefer the comments somebody made earlier
the that he is like his Pokémon, okay?
When they're children, rape tone was saying, "My dad could rape
your dad." It's like that's insane. Like is your dad a rape Pokémon?
What do you mean you're going to deploy your There we go. This
is he said okay. >> I feel like we all see this, right?
That he's in a Pokéball. I'm going to tactically I'm going to
tactically deploy my rape father. That's awesome. That's That's
cool, man. That's totally normal. Anyway, the reason why I think
it's important to identify exactly who Emiru was talking about
um and I'm I'll explain to you why in a second is because bad
actors can still get away uh by uh engaging in denial to their
communities. Well, here's Teck Tone
By the way, clearing things up, she ain't talking about me. She's
talking about Lacari and Miz. She ain't talking about me, okay?
Hey, let's keep that [__] 100%. ACTUALLY, THEY LIED
ABOUT ME. [__] HEY, THAT'S ABOUT MIZ AND
GET THE [__] OFF OF ME. GET the [__]
off of me. Everybody's saying, "Oh, that's you." No, it's not.
No, it's not.
Twitter disagrees with you? Yeah, because that fits their head
canon.
I think he realized that he basically just made it that Emiru
has to respond again, right? Like he realized he's a complete
for doing this. That's why you get the second clip later in the
stream, I assume, where he says, "Well, I just assumed Emmy didn't
mean me." Cuz like why would he say it? But he's already [__]
it up for her directly. She's a [__] idiot.
Like she had the ability to just walk away and now he's like,
"Uh no, I'm not a rape I Why would she be talking about me there?
She didn't name me." By the
Like I just don't understand. Emiru has been victim to
assault. Like how do you how do you not make this clear? And
And that's my point because
the this condemnation
was left vague so that like Techtone, Rapetone, can get away
with saying this
Okay? I don't know if that if that was her actual intention here.
Okay? I don't Why is Techtone streaming from Zoro Ranch? Techtone
is a performative loser who bought a Orthodox like Christian
cross and eagle, has a longhorn on his wall, this little wooden
cabinet, these antique little sh lamp shades here, these lamps,
and then a bust for some reason that totally clashes with everything
of Marcus Aurelius. He like went to conservative Build-A-Bear,
conservative Build-A-Set,
Like like Tucker Carlson, except his decorator is far worse than
Tucker Carlson. His decorator might be himself,
it's terrible. It's awful.
It's God-forsaken, okay? It's not anything to do with Techtone
anymore. Yeah, to to Emiru, but this is the result. This is the
desirable outcome for Techtone, for Rapetone.
This is crazy slander?
Brother man, do you really think she supports Techtone? Did you
not understand the words that came out of my [__]
mouth? I said, because of her
that was left vague
and did not mention names, Techtone can get away with lying.
Did you not understand that I said
and I'm going to repeat it one more time for your dumb ass.
If she had said Techtone, Lacari, whoever she's calling out in
this situation, like directly said, "I'm not associated with
these people."
I mean, she's the funny thing is is I wonder if she didn't want
to do that because here's the problem, okay? She's technically
being sued by Miskif for defamation right now. So, she could
probably name Techtone and Lacari directly, but she might actually
get into trouble if she names Miskif directly. And so, if she
was the this could be what happened in her mind where she was
like I like I'm going to name names, but I can't name Mizkif.
So, I have to name Tectone and Lacari. And then she's like just
throwing those two under the bus without Miz. That might have
That might have been something, you people weren't willing to
be okay with. People were not okay with. I I could see that.
Dude, you're making it clear to your audience that she's friends
with them. She was friends with them. Hello, she She literally
is friends with them. Why Why would somebody be arguing that
she's not Wait, what? Make it clear to your audience that she's
friends with them. And was friends with them. Oh, sh-
What are you talking about? She was, whether you want to admit
or not, friends with them. This is the reason why Tectone can
get away with saying, "Oh, we're still good friends."
>> Dude, the face I don't know, the face just gets me,
man. It just gets me.
I don't know if she's still friends with them. How the [__]
am I supposed to know if she's still friends with them? But she
absolutely was friends with them.
You can I mean, I'm I'm pretty confident at minimum she is very
good friends. And I say that not in Like she could be dating
Asmongold, I don't know. But at minimum, she's like very good
friends with Asmongold.
I do feel This is why she should be able to make the comments
on politics, okay? Because she is friends with Asmongold. And
I don't think
I think Asmongold's probably, and you guys are going to hate
this, he's probably actually a really nice person to be friends
with on a personal level.
He seems like everything I've seen of him, when he like talks
about how he handles his friendships, when he gives people advice,
when he like comments on his friends on stream, probably like
an actual good person to be friends with.
like he um But that's why she should be willing to comment on
the politics cuz she should be able to differentiate herself
without having to disavow him in a personal sense, right? So,
anyway, but they are good friends. Maybe even say the same thing.
You can turn around and say Hassan, you went on that podcast,
too. Right? You went on that podcast as well.
I'm pretty sure she's still friends with Asmongold, but I think
Hassan got to watch the video. Watch Load it up, Hassan. The
I'm Your Boy or Holler at Your Boy, whatever the Whatever that
guy's name. Load up the tweet, Hassan. Watch the video.
Tell me lies. Tell me sweet little lies. Tell me Come on, Hassan.
Load it up. >> what my opinion is on RapeTone and Asmongold,
right? Perhaps there's not a lot of room for speculation on whether
or not I actually like Asmongold or there's any speculation on
whether or not I like RapeTone, for example. Do you know why
there's no speculation for that? Because I've made my position
very
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. It's a Teamfight Tactics. I don't know
how I got involved playing that
Hold on. You got to Listen, at the start he says, "I have no
idea how I started playing Teamfight Tactics." >> you know,
TFT uh Teamfight Tactics. I don't know how I got involved playing
that game.
>> You know what I've been doing on my my days off recently?
Is I usually don't have to be at my computer to like do like
work. I'll just buy my friends. I'll buy them games that I like
playing and make them stream it. pretty on Discord. I'm going
to be honest. Like I was on a Discord call with somebody. Like
I was extremely cute to them.
until 7:30 in the morning, all right? I stayed up so late last
night. I played three games of Mega Bombs with my friend. And
I got on Discord and I was like I I I was screen sharing and
I just kept dying on map one. I go to Asmon's party. I haven't
really decided yet. I don't know. Um I'm going to lay down, maybe
take a nap, and I'll be back on Asmon here. Hello. Hello. How's
it
How are you lately?
Yeah. I'm I'm going to I'll give the second one away to someone.
I don't know who yet. This I picked this one up last night uh
from the store. Did you get the Switch, too? No, I didn't. I
went to a It's actually kind of funny. I I went to the midnight
release of the Switch last night with somebody else, and they
got their Switch, but I didn't get my Switch. And so, I got home.
I got home about like probably 3:00 in the morning almost. No,
no, no, 2:00, 2:00, 2:00, cuz I had I had I had to do a meeting
at 2:00 a.m. Actually, I didn't buy it. It was given to me. I
I I have a Switch,
And I will repay that debt. I got 65 Zach raw raids. Uh true
statement, absolutely. You know what I mean? You want to be a
simp for someone who's not your girlfriend? Well, I mean, sometimes
maybe maybe to get her, you know, like you got to capture them,
right? It's like you know like whenever you're hunting and like
you're trying to capture like a like a rabbit, right? Or something
like that or a like a rat, you could say. Uh you put um food
[__] food under a box. A rabbit. >> Like as
soon as they get in the box, you get the box, right? You can
I hate to say this, but if you're lying to a girl, A rabbit.
A rabbit. Uh Diggers thank you for the raid. Let's go. >> way
to do it is to emotionally manipulate them. If you can activate
their emotions on something, you can tell them anything that
they want to hear, and you can get them to believe it, right?
And so, played uh So, like as much as that's not conclusive,
and I don't even know the timing on like those when they play
TFT, when the statements were made on stream. I don't know any
of that stuff, okay?
But I'm just saying that
I just wouldn't bet against the the Emmy schizos, okay? They
They tend to just
They tend to do their work, okay? Their work tends to be high
quality. It tends
I don't know what to tell you, man. I don't know I don't know
what to tell you. I've always found it strange that she is actually
close friends with
And the reality of the matter is who you keep as your a company
and maybe you can tell me that she's not friends with Asmongold.
I don't think that's the case, though. But who you keep company,
who you keep close company, says something about you. Okay?
There's a reason why they even in the Ice clip even in the Ice
clip
Uh this is just wrong, Story Writer
If Yeah, this is the thing, okay? Emiru
is like a ride or die, and everybody seems to forget this. Everybody's
like, "Oh, she's just a She rose up to the way to the top." Nope.
When Mizkif got his [__] nuked, Emiiru was the one
who came out right away and was like,
"Fuck you. Mizkif's awesome. [__] you. I ride or
die with Mizkif." She immediately was like, "Yeah, no, I'm I'm
in." She could have She could have easily been like, "You know
what? Miz is a little weird. I'm actually I'm out of here." But
she didn't. She She actually stood by that guy, tried to help
him get back on his feet, right?
Her mod, who was Asmongold's mod,
is saying,
"Her mod, who was Asmongold's mod as well, is saying, 'Oh, Hasan,
thoughts on ice, lmao.
What's next? You're going to talk about
No, Emiiru was big enough Emiiru was big enough when the Mizkif
stuff happened that she could have gone and done her own thing.
She was fine. For sure.
My opinion. Like, it's not an accident. It's also not an accident
as to why she's been like even more silent, I I would say, than
even her roommates and
Asmongold says, "Content creators who engage in anti-ice rhetoric
deserve more hate and harassment." Oh! Substance quote tweet.
Substance quote tweet. Let's go. Wait, I didn't know Substance
tweeted this. I must have missed that.
Substance also tweeted. >> People get mad and they talk
[__] about this, but at the end of the day, I'm glad
that more people are starting to speak up against them. And I'm
glad that And for the record, Twitch can suck my too. I'm sorry.
I know there's a bunch of wonderful, kind, woke individuals that
work at Twitch, but you see this [__] every day.
I know you see this [__] every day, and you're terrified
of doing anything about it, and you never actually allow the
terms of service to be followed through on. Okay? This is one
of your top content creators. And the reason why you apply double
standards is because you're afraid if you actually dare to ban
Asmongold, you will have a metric ton of of criticism coming
from possibly the Republican administration, possibly the Trump
administration. You'll have J.D. Vance talk about it. You'll
have Elon Musk talk about it. And you don't want that smoke.
In every other case, I would say Hasan is wrong, but in this
I I don't know how much Asmongold's violating the TOS directly.
Almost certainly some of the stuff's violated the TOS. I do actually
think he's correct on this one.
And I do think this is like I think every platform knows right
now
wait a couple years. Do not get on the bad side of this administration
cuz they'll just attack you. They'll just literally they'll make
an example of you, right? They'll like destroy your company for
fun. They don't care about the jobs. They don't care about anything.
They'll they'll kill your company for fun. Okay, so you're terrified.
So you let him run Is that the Malay quote tweet or something
about that? >> every day. Obviously no such consideration
is given to someone like myself. Because why? Well, because I'm
anti-Israel. And when you're anti-Israel, it doesn't matter.
No one is going to AOC is not going to come out and be like
This guy just bankrupted his country in record time.
Very cool. Love having that guy in the fold. It's cool.
Kamala Harris is not going to come out and say Hassan should
not have been banned off Twitch. But they know that if Asmongold
gets banned, JD Vance is probably going to say something. And
that's precisely the reason why they're terrified of doing something
about it. When you got one of your largest content creators running
around saying we should do harassment to people who speak out
against ICE. People get mad and they talk [__] about
this, but at the end of the day I'm glad that more people are
starting to speak up against it. And I'm glad that I'm going
to be honest I'm glad that more creators are getting hate on
social media for not supporting ICE and for making virtue statements
against ICE. I think that content creators need to deserve I
think they deserve and I think they need a lot more hate and
they need a lot more pushback for being able to virtue signal
about how bad ICE is. I do. I'm really glad to see more people
speaking up against it. Also Twitch knows Mold could run a kick
where you can never fully abandon Twitch. What are you talking
about? If I was a single platform streamer, I would just go to
YouTube. That much is very clear especially after this last week's
shenanigans. Are you kidding me? What are you talking about?
Also Twitch knows Mold could run a kick where you would never
fully abandon
I mean Hassan could go to kick too. Kick would love to have Hassan.
>> was a single platform streamer, I would just go to YouTube.
That much is very clear especially after this last week's shenanigans.
Are you kidding me? The only reason why I The only reason why
I didn't I don't dual stream my YouTube is because like well,
there's a reason why I have 38,000 people watching today, okay?
Whereas this last week it was like sub 20k. It's because single
platform streaming is obviously boosting my visibility on this
platform, a platform where I have to engage in ideological warfare
against people who are literally making this space a more toxic
place for trans content creators, for smaller content creators,
for content creators with immigrant background. I can't [__]
do that. I'm sorry, okay? Even though I make Aw, come on, man.
You got to power through that a little bit. A little bit you
got to power through that.
I feel like that's a little that's a little weak.
I can't multi-stream to YouTube. My nummies go down.
Dude, okay. Thank you for the wall update on Javier Milei.
Do not send me other Javier Milei pictures because there are
a lot of those. That exact picture you sent me, that exists in
like a hundred different iterations with things that aren't the
wall, okay? Don't Don't Google Javier Milei and anything to do
with Israel. Don't do it. >> [__] money on
YouTube. The reason why I'm [__] streaming on Twitch
is because I got to go where the [__] people are.
I got to go where the reactionaries are, and I got to [__]
fight the the the same fires that they're putting out, okay?
Well, people get mad when they talk >> he's saying go harass
people who take a negative stance against ICE,
He said, "Go harass people who are taking a negative stance against
ICE, okay?" Woke is back. He can say this all day, every day.
It doesn't matter, okay? Our woke warriors will be out there
in the [__] trenches defending people who are taking
that stance. The only reason why he's chirping like this is because
he knows the cultural shift is here, and even he recognizes it.
Yeah, go ahead, suck my dick. Talking about how, "Oh, yeah, you
guys should go and continue harassing people who are uh saying
[__] ICE."
He's a [__] Here's Here Here he is talking about
it again. You know, um I haven't seen the Emeru apology stuff.
I was going to talk about it because like Asmongold apparently
uh Emeru got yelled at cuz Woke is back. Uh-huh.
We do have to do something about this. And I will continue like
I think I might ramp up my hostility towards the people online
that are pushing these woke narratives. I think we might need
to ramp it up. And How are you going to ramp it up? How are you
going to [__] ramp it up? Yeah, he's literally saying
to harass Emeru's roommate, Sinna.
Hasan, one time when he basically said um he was watching a clip
from from stream, and he's getting very mad about it, okay? He
said, "I don't I hate this. I wish I never had to do this, but
these people, they're just they just keep doing it. They won't
leave it They won't leave it alone." I didn't realize that he
was just lying to his whole audience that he loves drama. That
I thought I was like, "Dude, I love this. This is awesome. This
is why I wake up in the morning. Covering stuff like this is
[__]
Like, I'm sorry that you have to be where you don't like to be,
but he was lying to the audience. He was saying that he hated
it so much, but he loves